JANNA LEVIN: Thanks
for having me.
It's really great
to be here Google.
I'm always curious as
to what Google is up to.
So maybe I get to ask you
guys questions after the talk.
It's about this detection
that I want to talk today.
I don't know if people heard,
on February 11th, 2016, just
this year, there was
an announcement made
about an otherwise very
obscure experiment nobody
had heard of before.
And suddenly, it was on the
cover of all the newspapers
internationally.
It was reported everywhere,
radio and television,
that this obscure
experiment had announced
the discovery of the century,
the first human-procured
recordings of
gravitational waves.
Did you hear this?
And gravitational waves
were cited as ripples
in the shape of spacetime.
That's what everyone
always says.
They're ripples in the
shape of spacetime.
They're literally a squeezing
and stretching of space.
The recording that
was captured was
of the collision of
two black holes that
rang the space and
time around them,
like mallets on a drum
ringing the drum of spacetime.
Those waves in
the shape of space
emanated out, traveling
at the speed of light,
although they are
not light, which
I think is a very
important distinction I'll
try to emphasize.
And they took a 1.3-billion-year
journey before sloshing over
the Earth and striking
this experiment.
Did you hear the
gravitational waves?
OK.
We're going to listen
to them anyway.
[RUMBLING SOUND]
Ooh, that's loud.
[SQUELCHING SOUND]
Loud was good.
[RUMBLING SOUND]
[SQUELCHING SOUND]
So that sound was not so loud.
They were actually listening
to the detector in the control
room when this struck, and
it was too quiet to hear.
It would actually probably
have been loud enough
to hear by the human
ear through the speaker
system in the control room.
But it happened so fast that the
operators in the control room
couldn't have parsed it, really.
It happened too fast.
But I want to discuss why we're
talking about this as sound,
really.
That's the part I
want to emphasize.
I know people have heard this.
They've heard the recording.
They saw the discovery
in the papers.
But I think that people are
still quite unsure what it all
means, why it's a sound,
why it isn't a picture,
and what this discovery means.
So that's kind of what I
want to pick apart today
before we do the Q and A.
Here is the universe,
sort of, as we know it.
This is from the Sloan
Digital Sky Survey.
Every object in this
survey has been observed.
This is not a cartoon.
These are real observations.
Those objects are all galaxies.
So each galaxy has 100
billion stars or more.
And there are a hundred
billion galaxies
in the observable universe,
as many galaxies as there
are stars in the Milky Way.
And it just goes on and on
forever, every one of these
being an entire galaxy.
Now, so much of what we know
about the universe, almost
everything that we know
about the universe,
comes to us from light, from
things like telescopes, right?
We sit on this planet,
for the most part.
Occasionally we put
something in orbit
around the Earth or the sun.
But we just from the confines
of this rocky planet,
basically, we collect light
and take pictures of the sky.
And we've amassed this
incredible story--
that the universe is 13.8
billion years old, that it's
full of galaxies,
that we are not
at the center of the universe,
that the universe expands,
that there was a big bang
13.8 billion years ago.
We know that there
are black holes, maybe
hundreds of thousands, maybe
millions in every galaxy.
We think there are supermassive
black holes, millions
or billions of times
the mass of the sun.
And their centers
are these galaxies.
We know that there's
dark matter-- matter
that we can't see but
we only indirectly
see its effects--
and dark energy.
But what else is out there,
is sort of the question?
If we know that there is
dark matter and dark energy,
are there other dark things
that we simply can't see?
And black holes are an
example of dark things
that usually we can't see.
So here is a astronomical image.
Again, this is not a cartoon.
This is a real image of a galaxy
in the direction of Hercules,
the constellation Hercules.
It's an entire galaxy,
hundreds of billions of stars.
It's actually a very big galaxy.
It's bigger than that.
In the center is a supermassive
black hole, we suspect.
And why do we suspect it?
Because we see these huge
jets coming out of the galaxy
that are powered by
material being taken down
by the black hole and spat
out before it falls in.
People often ask me, how
did the material get out
from inside the black hole?
Nothing can escape a black hole.
It doesn't come from
inside the black hole.
It actually never
makes it inside.
It gets shot out along
these tremendous jets,
and those jets are millions
of light years across.
And we see them from
this great distance,
and that's how we figured out
black holes are out there.
But essentially, black holes
should be invisible to us,
usually.
So there's lots of
black holes out there
that we simply
couldn't see, that
are too dark to possibly see.
And that's where the
gravitational waves come in.
So gravitational waves are a
way of observing the universe,
but not through light.
The gravitational-wave
observatory
that made that discovery is
not a telescope of any kind.
It doesn't take
pictures of the sky.
It actually makes a
recording of the ringing
of the shape of spacetime.
So you want to try to
get into that stuff?
So let's try to get
into that stuff.
It was interesting
that all of this
does come from
Einstein's theory.
So a lot of people were
saying very excitedly,
this was the confirmation
of Einstein's theory
of relativity.
But nobody was that
surprised about
this particular confirmation.
In some sense, it was
much more the fact
that it could even
be done at all.
So here's an example
of spacetime.
You know, if we're in
the space of this room,
we don't see curves
in spacetime.
This is Einstein's theory.
Einstein's theory is that
spacetime is curved in response
to mass and energy.
But we can't see these curves.
If you were to float in empty
space, and you were to, like,
throw objects in
empty space, they
would trace straight
lines, right?
If you're an astronaut, and
you're far from the Earth,
and you can't see any stars,
and you were to just throw-- I
don't know.
What do astronauts
have their hands on?
I don't know.
A bolt, something, a tool.
It would travel in a
straight line, right?
So if I imagined painting
those curves in spacetime,
I would imagine painting
a straight line grid.
This is a way to give you
an explanation of what
curved spacetime-- an
intuition for what it's like.
Einstein's theory says if I put
a big mass in that space time
like a star, it will curve
the shape of space around it.
And you already know
that to be true.
If I take this clicker
and I throw it,
you know it's not going to
travel in a straight line,
right?
It's definitely going to trace
an arc and fall to the Earth.
And if we could
paint all the paths
that I could imagine
of throwing probes,
you could actually paint the
curved spacetime around it.
And so intuitively,
it's actually--
it seems like such a huge
leap, but yet intuitively,
we all know it's true.
We live in a spacetime
where things do not
travel in straight lines.
And those paths that
things travel along
when they're free and
weightless, like this would
be if I let it drop or like
it would be if I threw it,
those are the
curves in spacetime.
So when Einstein
proposes this theory,
you know, it takes him forever.
He really struggles
with the mathematics
of general relativity.
But when he comes
up with the theory,
the first thing he
turns to is the topic
of gravitational waves.
And here's the reason why.
If spacetime is curved
by heavy masses,
then if those masses
move, the curves
have to move and adjust
to follow it around.
Surely if the sun were to go
halfway across the universe,
the curves it creates
around it must also move.
And those are the
gravitational waves.
What happens is
the curves in space
actually have to move and adjust
slower than the speed of light
or at the speed of
light, in this case,
because no information, not
even gravitational information,
can go faster than
the speed of light.
So these waves curve and
adjust and follow the mass,
and then wave outward
throughout spacetime.
Now, Einstein many times said
gravitational waves are real,
they're not real, they're
real, they're not real.
Over decades, he was
changing his mind
and writing different papers.
Sometimes he would
write a paper that
said gravitational
waves are not real.
And between acceptance of
the paper for publication
and print, he would write it
saying-- which one did I say?
Not?
That they are.
OK?
So he changed his
mind many times.
This is not simple stuff.
So this is from 1915 to 1916.
In the '30s, people
are still arguing
if gravitational waves are real,
some people even in the '60s.
In the early '70s,
very visionary people
like Kip Thorne start
to become convinced
that gravitational
waves are real
and that somehow, they're
fundamental to our whole theory
of gravity hanging together.
This is a computer
simulation, now modern times,
of two black holes colliding.
And it's a very formal
mathematical system
based in relativity.
This problem, even on
a computer-- since you
guys like to code a
lot, will appreciate--
was so hard, even though
we know Einstein's
theory of curved spacetime.
We can write the equations down.
We can plug them
into a computer.
It doesn't just run.
It was a numerical problem
that seemed insoluble.
And that's because gravity
is very non-linear.
As a spacetime would curve
and change with the two
black holes, it would
feed back into itself
in such a complicated
way that they
couldn't get the codes to run.
It took 30 years,
three decades, for them
to write the codes properly and
solve that numerical problem.
So here is a beautiful
visualization of one
of the numerical solutions.
It shows two black holes.
They've helpfully painted
the curves in spacetime
around it, kind of contours.
If you can see the
red coming out,
those are the
gravitational waves
emitting as two black
holes bang on the drum,
ringing spacetime,
sending the waves outward
at the speed of light.
The two black holes collide.
They make a bigger
black hole, which
just settles down to this
perfect shape and goes quiet.
And that's the prediction.
This prediction is already--
this must be many years old,
this simulation,
maybe 10 years old.
And it's an incredibly
accurate prediction
of what the gravitational
waves would sound like.
They would travel
through the universe
getting quieter and quieter
until it hit the Earth.
This is-- I'm going to
show you a much less
sophisticated simulation
that's based more
in analytical calculations.
I'm going to show you the
orbits of two black holes.
I'm not going to show the
contours of the space.
But we're going
to listen to them.
So this is what it would
sound like if you could record
the ringing shape of the drum.
So one of the black
hole paths is yellow.
One is red.
And they're going to start
to spiral in together.
[BUZZING SOUND]
So these two black holes
are equal in mass, which
is why they're both moving.
One's not heavier
than the other,
so they're both whirling around.
And as they get
closer together, you
can hear the frequency goes up.
And eventually,
they're going to merge.
So you heard that chirp, and
that's a lot like the chirp
in the actual signal.
You see how similar they are.
That's what's called the
chirp, is when it sweeps up
in frequency as they collide.
Now, even now, you sort of
maybe have a better intuition
of what the waves are.
But why are they sound?
If you were an astronaut
floating nearby
those two black
holes colliding, you
would not be able to see them.
But it could ring your eardrum.
I mean, I always say that.
I'm not-- I don't know
anatomy that well.
So I have talked to people
who study the ear in detail.
And they say it's plausible.
You know, I've never tried to
do the experiment, floating
near a black hole.
But if you heard that, you'd,
like, want to get out of there.
If you're floating
near darkness,
and you hear this chirping
up, it's like time to scoot.
So technically, it is
very much like sound.
It's not just a weak analogy.
You know, I can take
any kind of light waves
and translate them into sound.
That's not what's happening.
This is not light.
It's literally
vibrations on the drum.
And so, it's almost like
having an electric guitar,
where you pluck the string,
and it makes no sound
until you amplify it, until you
record the shape of the string
and you amplify it.
That's kind of what
this instrument does.
It records the
shape of the ringing
drum-- we'll talk
about that more--
and it plays it back as sound.
Here's another pair
of black holes.
One is much heavier, so
its orbit is in yellow.
It hardly moves because it's 10
times heavier than the other.
The other moves much more.
You can see the orbits of
black holes are pretty crazy.
They're not like
solar-system orbits.
When they get close together,
they get pretty wild.
And you can hear the
difference between this one
and the previous one.
[TICKING SOUND]
Hear how it gets quiet?
And then louder?
So we can hear that the whole
system's moving like this.
We can hear that they're
not on circular orbits.
And we can even hear
that they're spinning,
if you know how to listen.
[WHIRRING SOUND]
OK.
And then they merged.
But it still chirps.
That chirp is a
real characteristic
of all these black-hole systems.
Sorry.
Did I touch the volume?
OK.
Wait.
Before I do that, let
me go back for a second.
At the time that people decided
to build this instrument,
LIGO-- so the experiment,
this obscure experiment
no one had ever heard of
that made this detection,
is called LIGO.
It's the Laser Interferometer
Gravitational-Wave Observatory.
It actually made the
detection in September--
September 14th, 2015.
They didn't announce
it until February,
but it made the
detection in September.
This experiment was
dreamed up in the late '60s
and sort of started to spread.
Different ideas were
spreading about trying
to do something like this.
But one of the original
architects was Rai Weiss.
He was a young professor at MIT.
He didn't understand the
general theory of relativity.
He was trying to teach
it because MIT said,
you're running a
gravity-research program.
You should teach
general relativity.
And he says, I
couldn't tell them
I didn't know general
relativity, right?
So he starts to
teach this class.
He says, I was bumbling, but
the students didn't walk out.
And the reason they
didn't walk out
is because he was dreaming up
ways to actually do experiments
with the theory.
And that's when he
dreamt up this idea.
Look, if there are
gravitational waves,
he thought, and they
come across the Earth,
then things will bob on the
wave by the time they get here.
If I could suspend
mirrors very delicately,
they would sort of bob
as the wave passed.
And if I could keep track of the
distance between those mirrors,
I would know if they had
moved slightly apart and in,
and I could record the
shape of the ringing drum.
So if you could time-- had
extremely accurate clocks,
you would be able to do that
with what we call just one
arm, just two
mirrors in a vacuum
so the laser light
doesn't get scattered.
And shine the laser light
between the mirrors,
and with a very
precise clock, you
could keep track of
where those mirrors are.
We don't have such
precise clocks.
So instead, he thinks of
an interferometer, which
is two arms in an L-shape.
And you'll see the LIGO
instruments in a second.
And the light comes back
and goes down the two arms
and comes back.
And if it traveled the same
distance in both directions,
then the light would
interfere perfectly.
And if it travelled
different distances,
then it would
interfere imperfectly,
and the waves would create
what's called a fringe pattern.
And so it's a much
simpler detection
to look at the fringe
pattern than it
is to try to use a clock.
And he started
building this machine.
It was 1.5 meters.
He was building in a place
called the Plywood Palace.
It was this ramshackle
structure that was thrown up
during World War II.
And it was supposed
to be torn down,
and they didn't tear it down.
It was supposed to
last for 10 years.
It wasn't torn down
for another 50 years.
And they used to punch
holes in the ceiling
and break the pipes.
And they would literally
perform experiments and go right
through several stories.
And it was a crazy place.
Nine Nobel Prizes came
out of the Plywood Palace.
And it was almost the
crappiness of the structure
that allowed them to just
be free to experiment.
He describes that when he
began these experiments,
everybody thought he was crazy.
First of all, they said,
it will never work.
Technologically it's impossible,
what you're trying to do.
Because by the time the
gravitational waves get here,
their variations in distance
that we expect it to affect
is a billionth of a trillionth
of the length of your machine.
OK?
A billionth of a trillionth
of the length of your machine.
So a 1.5-meter machine
isn't going to get anything.
One of his colleagues from
MIT said, you couldn't even
record the sun exploding.
I could look out the
window and do better.
You know?
And eventually, he
ran out of funding.
His grants were turned down.
And then he found
out after he had
been declined from his grants
and people started telling him,
you're not going to get
tenure and you're not
going to succeed, he found
out that a German group which
had read his grant to review
it for the National Science
Foundation had started to build
these instruments, but bigger
and better.
So there he is in this
ramshackle structure
with no money.
People are against him.
They don't even believe
gravitational waves are real.
They certainly don't
think black holes
are real at this stage in time.
And he's about to
lose out, right?
He's about to lose out.
And he says, then what happened
is I met Kip, Kip Thorne.
Kip Thorne is the
iconic astrophysicist
from your part of the world.
He's a Caltech professor, very
theoretical, very brilliant
man.
And they go on this
campaign together.
So skipping ahead a bit,
50 years later, 800 people
invested in the experiment,
nearly a billion dollars.
Two instruments that
each span four kilometers
make the detection
of the century,
and it's not an easy 50 years.
It's an arduous 50 years.
Here is the full-scale detector.
This is an instrument
in Hanford.
These are the arms.
The mirrors are suspended
at the ends of these arms,
and the laser light travels
along those vacuums.
That's the site in
Louisiana, and you
can tell because it's swampy.
There are alligators
and bass and things
like that in the swamps.
And so here we're going
to see the laser light.
This part is a
cartoon, obviously.
You can't go inside the beam.
But that vacuum wasn't
built until 1998.
It has stayed in a vacuum.
It's two of the largest holes
in the Earth's atmosphere ever
made.
And these are the chambers
at the corner stations where
the mirrors are and the
beam splitters and all
of the optical components.
But the rest of it's just
vacuum and laser light.
So if that vacuum is broken, one
of the lead scientists told me,
we'd all go home.
It would all be over.
A lot of the expense is in
keeping that vacuum alive
or building it in
the first place.
There's the physical difference
between the two sites,
and they put them far
apart so that there's not
the possibility of
coincident false alarms.
And they're basically
recording devices.
So imagine some ripple
in the shape of space
comes from far away.
It rings the instruments.
They record it, and they
literally play it back as
sound in the control room.
You can listen to the
detector in the control room,
and it's constantly
noisy and humming.
They hear earthquakes in China.
They hear winds from the Gulf.
They have all kinds
of seismic activity.
Planes, the moon, the sun,
tides-- everything rings
this machine.
It's very noisy.
But the billionth
of a trillionth
of an arm, a
four-kilometer arm, amounts
to tiny variations in distance,
less than a ten thousandth
of a width of a proton.
And that's what they recorded,
which is quite remarkable.
[HUMMING SOUND]
This is a sound of the
instrument in the control room.
This is a noise.
This is what it sounds
like most of the time.
You can hear different
modes in that.
OK.
So this is what happened.
On September 14, there's--
Ray himself, 50 years later,
is still at the sites
working on the machine.
He was there on September 13
looking for radio interference.
And they were not ready
to run detections.
The machines were operational.
They were ready.
But some of the
algorithms weren't
ready for the data analysis.
And they were still doing
what they call an engineering
run, which is you run tests,
and you interrupt the machine,
and you see how it responds
to certain vibrations-- trucks
braking, banging
on it with hammers,
whatever they're doing.
Ray, luckily, his
wife says, come home.
So he puts down his
tools, and he goes home.
In the middle of the night
on September 14 in Louisiana,
in the middle of the night
in Hanford, Washington,
where the other instrument
is, the young scientists,
the people working on the sites
and the graduate students,
they're running their tests.
They're taking the
machine on and offline.
They finally decide
they've had enough.
It's too late.
And they go home.
4:50 AM, coming from
the southern sky after
a 1.3-billion-year journey,
within a span of an hour
of them leaving the
instrument in observing mode,
it strikes Louisiana.
10 milliseconds later,
maybe a little less,
it cruises across the continent
and rings the Hanford machine.
And it's this spectacularly
loud, beautiful event.
And this is what it was.
If you pointed a telescope--
this is a computer simulation,
not a picture, not a movie.
We couldn't possibly
see it with a telescope,
but this is what it
would look like if you
could look at the lensing
of the light behind the two
black holes.
One was about 29 times
the mass of the sun.
One was 36, I think.
They're pretty big black holes.
They're orbiting each other in
the final seconds of their life
together.
This is vastly slowed down.
They're going at a half to
0.7 of the speed of light.
Do you guys want
to see that again?
It's pretty great.
Let's see that again.
They're going about a
half the speed of light
up to almost 0.7
the speed of light,
like 70% of the speed of light.
They're about 200 kilometers
across, roughly, in size.
And all we caught was
the last four orbits.
That was the only part that
was loud enough to detect.
The event horizons
are empty space.
These are just
holes in spacetime.
The event horizons
touch and coalesce
and make a bigger black hole.
You can see how
deformed it looks.
And eventually,
that bigger black
hole rings down
and becomes quiet.
And we'll hear it
again in a second.
So look.
It's quite spectacular how
distorted they start to look.
And then they wobble together,
and they form one quiet,
spinning black hole.
You can't even tell that
black hole's spinning.
So here's what happened
at the observatories
1.3 billion years later.
[WHOOSHING SOUND]
So that's what they hear.
And again, it's slowed down.
[SQUELCHING SOUND]
[WHOOSHING SOUND]
They only hear it
once, of course.
It's just for effect that
they like to repeat it.
They had 200 milliseconds,
a fifth of a second.
So you've got to play
it four times to get
any kind of feeling out of it.
So it took them months
to analyze the data.
But that morning in
Europe, people wake up,
and they see this candidate
event in the data.
And there starts to
become a lot of chatter.
People start talking about it.
People wake up
eventually, 8:00 AM,
a few hours after it
happened, on the east coast
and eventually in Hanford.
And they start to
hear all this chatter.
And everyone's incredulous.
Somebody said, we just
turned the thing on!
There's no way.
People told me it
wouldn't be until 2018
that the first
detection was made.
And everybody told me it
wouldn't be black holes,
except for Kip Thorne.
Kip always said it's going
to be black holes first.
And [? Rana ?] who is one
of the experimentalists,
said this time we're
going to detect something.
And I said [? Rana, ?]
how can you be so sure?
And he said, I always say that.
I say that every run.
And he said he didn't even
look at the data for a day
because he was so incredulous.
He thought, this is ridiculous.
It's not real.
And they worried that it had
been intentionally injected
into the data as a false
signal, which is something
that the experimentalists do on
purpose to test the experiment.
They inject false
signals into the data.
So everyone thought, oh, God.
It's a blind injection.
This is ridiculous.
Mike Landry, lead
scientist at Hanford,
said he sat down that morning.
He was kind of pissed off
at the team of injectors.
He's like, what
are you guys doing?
We're not ready for this yet.
He sits down next to
the guy, and says,
are we going in a phase
of blind injection?
And the guy goes, like, no.
And he starts to ask-- he's
not allowed to ask, did you do
a blind injection of two
black holes colliding.
But he can sort of
ask, are we in a phase?
And he permutes the
question a few times.
And he keeps getting no.
And finally, he says, are
we in a phase of injections
of any kind anywhere?
And the guy says no.
And he says, I got cold,
is what he told me.
He said, I just went cold.
So on the telecom that
day, everyone's talking.
And many people are
raising the possibility
that it's a blind injection.
And somewhere in
the phone call, Mike
says-- I don't know how
many people are on the line.
Many, many voices on the line.
This is an 800-person,
international collaboration.
Mike says, it's not
a blind injection.
Someone else says, sorry, Mike.
You know, can you
say that again?
And that's when they started
to take it seriously.
It's pretty remarkable,
pretty fortunate.
It just shows that
quitting and going home
can be a very
effective technique.
So here, just to wrap up, is
another view of our universe.
Again, this is not a cartoon.
This is real data
from the Hubble.
Everything you're seeing
here is an entire galaxy.
And again, we can see
a lot in the universe.
But we know that all the
light that we receive,
that the constituents of the
universe that are luminous
is less than 5% of what
the universe has in it.
Everything else is dark--
dark energy, dark matter.
Among that 5%, black holes are
actually part of that small 5%.
But it just means
that the universe
is a vast amount
of dark phenomena
that we will never see with
telescopes, that we could only
hope to record with something
like a gravitational-wave
observatory.
So as the universe expands
and eventually gets darker,
the universe will also go quiet.
But in the meantime,
what we're really
hoping for from these
experiments is that they'll
detect things we haven't
even thought of before,
not just black holes, colliding
neutron stars, supernovae.
These are all game for
the gravitational-wave
observatories.
Neutron stars are stars
that didn't quite become
black holes, that
died and collapsed
but couldn't form black holes.
We expect to be able to
record a whole range,
as long as it's kind of
cataclysmic, big, astrophysical
phenomena.
But I think the real
hope is that we'll
detect something we've never
even thought of before.
OK.
Thank you.
I'd love to take
questions if people want.
[APPLAUSE]
Hi.
AUDIENCE: Hi, there.
I was curious how you
were able to locate
the event in three-dimensional
space with two interferometers.
JANNA LEVIN: It's not easy.
So I always liken this to
listening for your phone.
If you don't know where your
phone is, and it's ringing,
and you can't see it, it's
really hard to find your phone.
So you need two ears for any
kind of location ability.
And two interferometers helps.
If you only had one,
you would be saying,
it's kind of from over there,
like a whole huge patch
of the sky.
With two, you can do better.
But it's not great.
And so the future is expecting
many more interferometers,
a whole network on the
Earth, that there's
going to be an underground
instrument built in Japan.
There's one in Italy
that's almost online.
It's not as sensitive, but it
will really help with location.
There might be one in India,
which is going forward.
So that's going to help a lot.
Yes?
Hi.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So many questions, I
don't know where to begin.
Let me ask this one.
We know electromagnetic
radiation attenuates
with distance.
JANNA LEVIN: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Is that true of
gravitational waves, as well?
JANNA LEVIN: Yeah.
It gets quieter with distance.
So the closer you are, the
louder the event would be,
definitely.
And also, I should
point out that this
was the most powerful event
we've had since the Big Bang,
that we've detected
since the Big Bang.
The power that came out was
many billions and trillions
of times the power that comes
out of the sun in light.
So this is an incredibly
powerful event,
yet it's very quiet.
So if you blew up
a nuclear bomb,
you would not be able to
measure the gravitational waves
from it.
It would be totally
insignificant.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So you got this
event within a few hours
of turning the instrument on.
And now it's been
on for half a year.
Have you gotten many more?
JANNA LEVIN: Mhm.
OK, well I have to clarify
that I'm a totally theoretical
physicist.
So I don't build the machine.
And part of what happened
is that I started following
so closely this experiment
out of fascination--
because it was other.
I do a lot of theoretical work
about the colliding black holes
and the predictions.
But the idea that anybody
would take it seriously enough
to try to build a machine
just seemed ridiculous to me.
And so I am technically
not supposed to be
privy to the detections.
They did tell me, though.
I think I was the only
person that was officially
told of the detection before the
formal announcement on February
11.
And I can tell you that in
that February 11 announcement,
they did talk about another
bump, another signal that
looks like-- sounds like
two colliding black holes.
But it was nowhere near loud
enough or significant enough
for them to have made a claim
of a first detection with that.
It came later.
But it was significant
enough that it's helping them
assess how often this happens.
And so it looks like
there's going to be a lot
of black-hole-black-hole
collisions.
And the machine
is down right now.
It's been down since January.
It was not at
advance capability.
It was at-- it was better
than the previous generations
of machines.
But that's also why
nobody really expected
it to do anything right away.
It still needs to become
more sensitive by at least
a factor of three or four.
So they take it down, and they
tweak it, and they work on it.
And they're going to bring it
back up, probably, late summer.
And when we expect-- yes, we
fully expect maybe monthly
we're going to be hearing things
like black hole collisions.
We don't know if we're
going to hear anything else.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So somewhat
related to the attenuation
question-- so if you take a
bowl of water and you tap it,
you'll see waves.
And they will still
after a little while.
So is there a analog of
viscosity in spacetime that--
JANNA LEVIN: Not really.
It's interesting.
Nor for light.
So we still receive
light from the Big Bang
that's been traveling to
us for 13.8 billion years.
It's colder, right?
It's redder than
when it was created.
That has to do with the
expansion of the universe.
But light never tires.
Light never slows down like
what you're describing,
and there's no friction.
And in the same way,
there's really not
for gravitational waves.
They travel at the
speed of light.
And they also never
tire or slow down.
We say that all particles
that are massless
travel at the speed of light.
So you know the
wave-particle duality.
For light waves, there's
a quantum particle
called the photon.
And as long as that
photon is massless,
it will travel at
the speed of light.
If it has any mass, then yes,
it will slow down and stop.
And the graviton, which is the
particle analog or the particle
complement to the
gravitational wave,
is massless, as far
as we understand.
If it does have some small mass
and we're wrong about that,
then maybe they would
eventually slow down and stop,
and they would not be traveling
at the speed of light.
Any other questions?
Please.
AUDIENCE: Just a
quick follow-on--
JANNA LEVIN: Just come
up to the microphone.
AUDIENCE: A quick
follow-on to that--
we've not detected anything
like a graviton, right?
JANNA LEVIN: No,
it's way too hard.
So gravity is so weak,
we're nowhere near
the regime of probing
the quantum scale.
AUDIENCE: What would the-- I
mean, we kind of understand
the photon, how waves,
electromagnetic waves
and photons can
be converted back
and forth between each other.
Theoretically, what would
the gravitational wave
that they detected look
like for gravitons?
JANNA LEVIN: You mean if we
could probe the quantum level?
So the light in this room is
made up of so many photons
that it's really hard to notice
the particulate nature of it.
And similarly, the
gravitational waves
are made up of so many
gravitons that it's
impossible to notice the
particulate nature of it.
We haven't really
very well thought
of an experiment where
we could do that.
And probably, the energy
scale you'd have to get to
is something like
a million times
the Large Hadron Collider
energy, something like that.
So it's not an ambition
of the near future.
I mean, this was pretty crazy.
But that would be really crazy.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So it sounded
like-- I'm not sure
if I understood correctly.
But part of the
reason your software
was able to detect this
event and notify you guys--
because you kind of knew
what you were listening for.
You kind of had a prediction
for what it would sound like.
JANNA LEVIN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Is that correct?
JANNA LEVIN: Well,
that is correct.
One of the difficulties
in this experiment
is that the sound will often
be quieter than the noise.
And so they'll have to sometimes
run the predictions, especially
the numerical ones, in through
the data and filter it that way
and pluck it out.
But this one was so loud, it's
just right above the noise.
It's actually really loud.
So it's not as reliant
on that as we fully
expected things to be.
AUDIENCE: So is it that you
guys are actually just running
straight up anomaly detection?
And that's what you want
to use to possibly detect
other events in the future?
JANNA LEVIN: Yeah.
There's three or
four different teams
within the collaboration that
use different models to pluck
out different kinds of signals.
Some are burst signals.
Some are these-- what we call
compact binary coalescence,
things like black holes and
neutron stars and white dwarfs.
And some stochastic,
which is just noisier.
So there's all of these
different algorithms
that people write.
But I don't think
anyone expected
the first signal we detect
to be just noticeably loud.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
JANNA LEVIN: Sure.
It was just fast.
If it had been slower, I
think they would have heard it
in the control room.
It was that loud.
AUDIENCE: What is
the range of events
that you expect to be
able to detect with LIGO?
I understand there
are [INAUDIBLE]
like solar-system scale
interferometers for detecting
less energetic events or
more energetic events.
JANNA LEVIN: Right.
So the scale-- so
it happens that LIGO
is sensitive to the
human auditory range.
And that's just
strange, coincidence.
But these black holes
about this size, that's
the natural frequency
at which they
would emit gravitational waves.
But I think when they designed
the instrument-- you know,
this has been going
on for 50 years.
They were looking for supernova.
They were hoping to
hear things like that.
So it turns out that
the supernova might
be too quiet or too
difficult And that these
are much more populous.
And but yes, if you send
something in space--
and there is a project
to send something
into space-- millions
of kilometers apart,
they would be way outside
of the human auditory range,
way lower in frequency.
And they would be
detecting things
like supermassive black holes
colliding, bigger things, lower
frequency stuff.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
JANNA LEVIN: Hi.
AUDIENCE: How
close would we have
had to have been to the
colliding black holes
for them to kill us with
gravitational force.
JANNA LEVIN: That's an
interesting question.
It would be pretty hard to kill
us with gravitational waves.
They're so weak.
It would be really hard.
Like, to be squeezed
and stretched
like-- with your bare hands,
you could squeeze and stretch
me billions of
trillions of times
harder than a
gravitational wave could.
So I think I'd be much more
worried just about being
near the black holes generally.
But black holes aren't really
the engines of destruction
that they are portrayed to be.
If our sun was replaced
with a black hole tomorrow,
we wouldn't get sucked in like
a vacuum cleaner would suck us
in.
We would actually
orbit just fine.
The orbit would be
exactly the same.
It would be totally fine.
I mean, we'd be dead because
it would be cold and dark.
But we wouldn't fall in.
And we were actually very slowly
falling into a black hole now.
There's a supermassive
black hole
at the center of our galaxy
4 million times the mass
of the sun.
And we are, in fact, falling
into that black hole.
It's going to take a very
long time, very long time.
I really am worried
about other things.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: If you had an
infinitely sensitive detector,
where would you see
gravitational waves from?
Would it be from everything?
Or is it just--
JANNA LEVIN: Everything.
I would make gravitational
waves right now.
Infinitely sensitive
detector would pick up
gravitational waves from
all of us moving around.
And--
AUDIENCE: So you
have to be moving.
JANNA LEVIN: You
So a black hole
just sitting there
is not going to create
gravitational waves.
And it's just a funny
thing, that if, like,
a star exploded
perfectly symmetrically
in all directions,
it actually would not
create gravitational waves.
So you need what's called a
quadripolar or a certain kind
of asymmetry and
accelerations of masses.
Yeah.
But I'm not
spherically symmetric.
So I am making
gravitational waves.
AUDIENCE: About the one
that [INAUDIBLE] I'm
curious about what we
can know about them--
their relative size?
JANNA LEVIN: The
black holes, you mean?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, the
one that we have.
JANNA LEVIN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: --the sound.
What can we know about them?
JANNA LEVIN: Yeah.
It's pretty amazing.
So the details that we
seem to be able to extract
is one was about 29 times the
mass of the sun to begin with.
One was over 30.
By the time they collided,
they made a black hole maybe
about 62 times the
mass of the sun, which
means some of the energy
that we call E = mc2 energy
was emitted in the
gravitational waves.
A few percent of the
energy was emitted
in the gravitational waves.
And that's a tremendous
amount of energy.
That's just a huge
And that black hole is out
there right now, spinning.
They think they know it's
spinning very rapidly, probably
hundreds of times a second.
We saw the last
four orbits or so.
AUDIENCE: But that--
we know the location
now of this black hole?
JANNA LEVIN: Not very well.
Not very well.
It came from the southern
sky, somewhere over there.
They have a map, a
kind of a splotchy map.
It sort of came from over there.
It's 1.3 billion years away.
AUDIENCE: Are they
trying to find it?
JANNA LEVIN: They
can't find it anymore
because a telescope
can't see a dark object.
And so what they could try
to do is pinpoint the galaxy
that it lives in.
And then that
would tell it how--
something about the galaxy
might tell us something
about the black holes.
Very surprised that
they were that big.
That was something
that surprised people.
I wasn't particularly surprised.
I work on this a
lot, and I never
had a prejudice against
big black holes.
But a lot of people did.
They just thought it'll
be hard to make 'em.
But we-- the details of how to
make black holes is so hard,
I always thought, we're
probably not right about a lot
of that stuff.
So this was real
astronomical information
from the first detection.
It wasn't just we recorded
gravitational waves.
It was we've discovered the
first black-hole system,
and we've discovered the first
collision of black holes.
And we know things that
we didn't know before.
It's very cool.
They were very
lucky, very lucky.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: What other
gravitational wave detection
systems are coming online soon?
JANNA LEVIN: Yeah.
So there is this one
called KAGRA, which
is going to be underground.
And that helps isolate
it seismically.
So that will be helpful.
At some level, the
experiments are limited just
by quantum noise,
that there's nothing
you can do about quantum
mechanics, you know,
quantum fluctuations.
If you've heard about
Heisenberg's uncertainty
principle, it makes
it impossible.
In some regime, they're working
on suppressing quantum effects.
But eventually, they'll hit
some fundamental physical limit
where the Heisenberg uncertainty
principle says you can never
precisely locate an object.
And they'll be up against
that limit with the mirrors.
Right?
It's just-- it doesn't exist
in a precise enough location
anymore, technically.
But KAGRA will help
with seismic stuff.
And there's VIRGO which is an
Italy, which will hopefully
come online in the
summer, as well.
And then I mentioned
the one in India.
And there's GEO.
And I can't remember all
of the others right now.
TAMA, I think, is offline now.
But there's a whole
network of them.
Eventually in space-- that
would be very exciting.
Do you mean just gravitational
wave, by the way?
Or any gravity experiments?
AUDIENCE: Gravity waves.
JANNA LEVIN: Yeah.
So these are the ones.
They're are all of
the LIGO variety,
except the space-borne
LISA, which
would put three spacecraft,
disconnected, millions
of kilometers apart
from each other,
freely floating in space for
gravitational wave passes.
They all just bob,
and they keep track
of each other with a laser.
It's a really clever experiment.
There are some people who are
trying different ideas, again
going back to atomic clocks
and timing experiments.
But, you know, they're very new.
So it would be interesting to
see if anyone makes progress
with that.
I put the clock at--
we're counting down to 1.
But I think we
could take one more
question if somebody wanted to.
Yeah?
Or two more.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So I was thinking
about the earlier question
about the gravity waves.
So they were formed
by the black holes.
They came by.
They were detected.
And as they spread out,
they get weaker and weaker.
So they don't really dissipate
because there's no friction.
So what happens to them?
They just keep going on forever?
JANNA LEVIN: Well, just
imagine a light bulb up close
is very bright.
And far away, it's very dim.
And it's just cause you're
really intercepting less of it,
to some extent.
Right?
You're up close,
you're intercepting
a whole lot of the light.
But if it's very
far away, you're
getting very little of it.
The rest went to other
planets and other galaxies.
And, you know,
the farther out it
spreads, the less any small
patch of sky is going to get,
just like a light bulb.
AUDIENCE: But they
would ultimately
just keep going forever?
JANNA LEVIN: Yeah.
And if the universe
is finite, they'll
come back again, eventually.
They'll wrap around, and
then they'll come back again.
We'll hear it a second
time, even quieter.
AUDIENCE: The
picture of the wave
showed a vertical axis of
frequency oscillating around 20
hertz, I noticed, for
the last 0.4 seconds.
Surely the two objects were
actually orbiting much faster
than that, right?
So how does that relate to
their actual orbit [INAUDIBLE].
JANNA LEVIN: It
actually-- 20 hertz.
So the gravitational
wave is directly related
to the orbital rate.
So if you think about that,
that's extremely fast.
Right?
20 hertz is really
fast because you're
talking about something
200 kilometers
traveling several
hundred kilometers
and doing that orbit
many times a second.
So it's actually
incredibly fast.
OK?
And so you are going
near the speed of light
to be able to hit
that frequency.
And that's how-- there
was a previous question
about what sets the frequency.
That's sort of one
way to think about it.
You know, how far is
it going in an orbit?
And how fast is it going?
And that will set the frequency.
The gravitational wave is
twice the orbital frequency,
is the relationship.
I think that's it.
Thank you!
Thanks very much.
[APPLAUSE]